[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new Henry Cavill Superman
Man of Steel video they just confirmed
that he's actually coming back for more
movies we'd heard rumors earlier but now
it's finally been confirmed and we found
out which movies he's coming back for if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your Superman DC movie
predictions on the video so just working
our way down the list here starting with
number 5 because of all the Justice
League Snyder cut hype that's been
happening the past week in Zack Snyder
using a Man of Steel Superman rewatch
party with Henry Cavill to announce the
project a lot of us assumed that it was
implied he was at least in the process
of trying to work out a new deal with
Warner Brothers to come back for more
Superman movies or more Man of Steel
movies or at least show up as Superman
in some DC movie in some way because
he'd always said ever since Justice
League that he's not done with the
Superman character he has tons of ideas
he's been pitching Warner Brothers for a
while now on a Man of Steel sequel then
just a couple hours ago as I'm making
this video it was confirmed he is in the
process of hammering out a deal for
multiple get it multiple new Superman
crossovers in new DC movies it sounds
like some of them would be bigger roles
than others but we also found out which
movies those are going to be so for
right now the official reports are
saying that Warner Brothers is still not
publicly acknowledging that they're
developing Man of Steel 2 or another
solo Superman movie of any kind so
supposedly the new deal henry cavill is
making is to crossover with their
upcoming movies specifically Shazam to
Black Adam and then Aquaman 2 there's
also the flash movie too because they're
doing flashpoint obviously alternate
versions of characters would come in
handy as Superman would fit in pretty
well with that theme oh my god I created
the injustice Superman what have I done
now
and even though it goes without saying
it wouldn't make sense for him to do
Wonder Woman 1984 since they'd already
finished the movie and it's set before
Superman's pod crash to earth he's not
gonna show up during the Batman movie
with Robert Pattinson but they'd already
tried to get him to cameo at the end of
the first Shazam movie so we already
knew that they were trying to cross him
over with other new movies the rock also
has history with Superman in the Black
Adam movie that predates the Shazam
movie post-credit scene in Jason Momoa
has been trying to get everybody to
cameo
in his sequel so three right now the DC
movie release order works like this
first they're gonna do black Adam then
they do Shazam too
then they do Aquaman - Shazam - isn't
supposed to be a big black Adam
crossover maybe it post-credits scene
teaser at the end but Zachary Levi said
they don't have big plans for Black Adam
inches and - just because they're so
focused on this magic lands plot that
I've talked about in my previous Shazam
videos but because Superman and Shazam
have so much history in the comics and
Billie Freddie the rest of the Shazam
Lee idolized him it makes sense that
they try to use Superman in Shazam - at
least as a guide to help Billy with
problems that he can't solve with magic
or punching remember he's just a high
school kids so there's a lot that he
does not know about being a superhero
Superman even kind of becomes one of
Billy's guardians or a big brother
figure I wouldn't call him a father
figure to him but he does give off a lot
of Dada vibes when he's around the
Shazam Lee and because of that Shazam
Superman scene at the end of the movie
we know that Billy canonically already
knows Superman and based on the logic of
this scene there would have had to have
been at least a small time jump between
this scene at the rock of eternity where
they're putting the seven deadly sins
back in their prison then at some point
before the cafeteria seen Billy probably
was approached by Superman or even the
full Justice League who just saw what
happened in Philadelphia and as you
would expect Superman or the Justice
League to do fly their way to
Philadelphia to see what the hell was
going on and find out what exactly was
going on with this high school kid that
happens to look like an adult Zachary
Levi said he's been campaigning to try
and get Wonder Woman inches am2 as well
but I don't know that's gonna wind up
happening whatever their plans for
Wonder Woman three are because they're
definitely making Wonder Woman three so
she might be busy doing that he did not
say whether or not Billie has met the
entire Justice League yet but even if
Superman isn't a huge character during
the movie he could still give Billie
some sage advice and help train him a
little Superman is weak against magical
attacks but he can't help dish's Amalie
with all their other non-traditional
abilities like super-strength speed
flight
Superman
most of the stuff happening in shazam
two is more about what dr. sivana and
mr. mind are talking about at the end of
the movie which isn't really related to
Superman stuff so I'm not expecting
Superman to be a huge part of Shazam -
but number two Superman versus Black
Adam so the news report mentions
crossing over with the first Black Adam
movie which is a bit of a surprise it's
important to know though that Henry
cavils management company is run by The
Rock's ex-wife who also still manages
the rock so they've known each other for
a long time
they're already Bros in real life and
even before Henry Cavill signed with
their team the rock had been trying to
pitch Superman versus Black Adam to
Warner Brothers for a while I mentioned
this a little while ago in my Black Adam
video but boss logic said a couple years
ago after the rock had started to talk
more about the Black Adam movie openly
he contacted him to create some cool fan
art of Black Adam fighting Superman if
you've never seen it there's actually a
great animated movie where Superman
effectively goes up against Black Adam
he gets his ass handed to him but it's
still a really cool animated movie you
are my physical match but I sense one
critical difference a vulnerability to
magic last year we heard about the
Justice Society storyline that they were
planning on doing in the Black Adam
movie
there wasn't any mention of Superman
anywhere in that script but it sounds
like what's changed now is all the
Justice League Snyder cut stuff has been
going on since last November has healed
whatever wound there was between Warner
Brothers in Henry Cavill remember when
they announced that they were planning
on doing a Supergirl movie instead of
doing Man of Steel - there were a lot of
reports that the studio is actually just
using the press to bargain with Henry
cavils people because Henry Cavill
wanted more money but they didn't want
to pay him because of what happened with
Justice League so apparently they
probably never planned on doing a
Supergirl movie and they were just
holding that over his head in order to
get him to take a lower paycheck and I
think before the whole Justice League
debacle happened when it came out in
theaters I think originally Warner
Brothers never had plans to do Superman
versus Black Adam but when Justice
League did so poorly in the studio
changed all their DC movie plans maybe
they just warmed up a little to the idea
of a more hardcore version of Superman
inside the Black Adam movies but before
today before they made this big
announcement
was is that we wouldn't see Superman in
a Black Adam movie at least until one of
the sequels so number one I just did a
black Adam video a couple days ago I'll
link it at the end of this but I talked
about the Justice Society storyline
that's supposed to happen during that
movie at least in the current version of
the script as it exists now if they're
talking about putting Superman in the
Black Adam movie he obviously probably
would not be part of the Justice Society
just because within the context of the
DC timeline the Justice League still
exists in present day they're still
operating all over the world the whole
thing with the Justice Society in the
Black Adam movie is that they're
reforming in present day because they
fought him in the past at some point and
even though we haven't seen the Snyder
cut ending of Justice League yet during
the end of that movie they sort of
implied that he's back working at the
Daily Planet and things are relatively
back to normal
as for Superman in Aquaman 2 that just
feels like it would be the bro-down to
end all DC bro downs
Aquaman and Superman don't spend a ton
of time hanging out in the comics by
themselves unless it's a bigger Justice
League team-up story but they're both
children of two worlds they're both
treated like outsiders their whole lives
never really belonging anywhere but
somehow they feel responsible for
protecting everyone protecting the earth
as their chosen home so Superman going
to Atlantis just feels like a fun
premise even if it's only for a little
bit of that movie other than Black Manta
and dr. Stephen chin because of that
post-credit scene we don't really know
who the other villains of Aquaman 2 are
going to be or what the real threat will
be Black Manta by himself is one of
Aquaman's main villains but just by
himself he isn't powerful enough to take
on Aquaman with his new upgraded armor
and trident but Aquaman 2 is a little
further off so it's gonna be a while
before we get more news about that and
in terms of the Flash movie crossover
everyone's seen the original flashpoint
storyline that version of Superman's pod
was actually captured by the US
government and he was kept in captivity
so he winds up being this really altered
weakened version of Superman I don't
think that they would do something like
that in the flash movie
they already said that they're gonna be
changing the original comic book version
of flashpoint and they're not gonna be
doing all the Justice League characters
in that we don't know if there's gonna
be any kind of Batman or Wonder Woman
cameo but the way they've been talking
about the flash movie it wouldn't be
quite so dark as an injustice or
traditional flashpoint type of stories
so just expect it to be wildly different
from the
version of that storyline but even
though the new contract Henry Cavill is
signing right now is just for a couple
big crossovers I think if those go well
then they'll start talking about doing
more Superman solo movies so it's not
like they'll never do Man of Steel 2 or
whatever they want to call it man of
tomorrow henry cavill has actually
talked about his ideas for more Superman
movies and for the past couple of years
he was pitching new Superman movies to
Warner Brothers for whatever reason they
didn't want to make but what'll happen
is if we get any more news or concrete
details about which movies and what he'd
be doing in those movies of course I'll
do a video about it Zack Snyder will be
releasing a bunch more Snyder cut stuff
throughout the rest of the year as they
start to work on that movie so don't
worry those two be plenty of big DC
stuff happening and we have Wonder Woman
1984 coming out in August to everyone
click here for that Justice League
Snyder cut teaser trailer and click here
for my new black atom teaser and plot
synopsis breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]
you